[Aplausos]
y estoy seguro que todos ustedes
y todas ustedes han oído han escuchado o
han tenido que lidiar o navegar nuestras
calles las calles del norte de
centroamérica
enfrentando a las pandillas así que no
me voy a detener mucho en definir que
son como ustedes saben son grupos de
jóvenes más o menos entre 11 y no tan
jóvenes como yo y 55 años de edad
atados aún a un barrio y que comparten
una especie de identidad sin entidad
puede ser ms o puede ser 18 puede ser
otras identidades y lo que es importante
es recordar que se seed entidades no
nacieron aquí nacieron en el sur de
california a principios de los años 80 y
luego fueron exportadas aquí y tomaron
auge en este en este país como dije
anteriormente estos grupos no sólo están
en el salvador sino que también están en
guatemala en honduras aunque ahí tienen
ciertas expresiones distintas no tenemos
no tenemos en realidad no tenemos
números y que nos confirme a cuántos hay
pero los cálculos indican alrededor de
que 60.000 personas están vinculadas a
estos grupos y esto es importante
mencionarlo por dos razones en primer
lugar porque obviamente esto quiere
decir que no todos los jóvenes
salvadoreños son pandilleros porque hay
muchos más jóvenes
y 60.000 y en segundo lugar significa
que si acaso quisiéramos terminar como
algunos algunos abogan con el problema
de las pandillas metiéndolos todos a la
cárcel no o en el peor de los casos
matándolos a todos implicaría eliminar o
meter en la cárcel a 60.000 personas lo
cual es prácticamente imposible el
salvador de hecho es uno de los países
con la tasa más alta de encarcelación en
las américas con excepción de los eeuu
que es lo que hace particular a estos
grupos bueno algunos los vinculan o
mejor dicho los tildan como de grupos
organizadas de crimen organizado porque
se dedican a la extorsión muchos de
nosotros hemos sufrido de la extorsión
de las pandillas se dedican al sicariato
será matar por encargo y al tráfico o al
menudeo de al narcomenudeo de
y es de drogas usualmente como dije el
pandillero es alguien que tiene entre 11
y 50 o 21 años de edad son los más somos
son los más activos son usualmente
habitantes de zonas de escasos recursos
voy a volver a esto en otro momento son
jóvenes que estudiaron hasta sexto grado
no terminaron muchos de ellos no
terminaron ni siquiera la secundaria
llegaron hasta sexto grado estuvieron en
la escuela pero luego se salen son y
vienen de familias disfuncionales y aquí
déjenme hacer hacer el énfasis de que la
mayoría de ellos no es que venga de
familias
y desarraigadas o familias separadas con
muchas veces se dice más bien vienen de
familias disfuncionales en donde muchos
de ellos incluso crecieron con padre y
madre pero el padre y madre jamás le
prestaron atención o peor aún los
maltrataron mucho los trataron
brutalmente una de las cosas que cruza a
la mayor parte de pandilleros con los
cuales yo he hablado y que hemos
estudiado es que sufrieron de mucha
violencia cuando eran pequeños
de hecho hace varios años entrevistando
a un pandillero yo le decía mira y vos
sabes que te vas a morir en esto no vos
sabés que podés terminar mal este y por
qué estás haciendo esto por qué haces
esto y me dijo mire me dijo lo que pasa
es que cuando yo estaba creciendo a mí
en mi casa todo el mundo me pegaba mi
papá mi mamá todos me pegaban y yo no
podía hacer nada la diferencia es que en
la calle yo si puedo hacer algo y lo
hace devolviendo a la violencia que
recibió cuando cuando cuando era joven y
como dije antes muchos de estos crecen
sin fe
figura paterna o materna de referencia
que les guíe sin embargo hay que
recordar que no todos los jóvenes en
comunidades de discursos de escasos
recursos son pandilleros y más aún la
mayoría de salvadoreños no son
pandilleros si al final de cuentas es
sólo una porción que sin duda ejerce una
influencia un poder muy grande en
algunos sectores y que determina mucho a
las dinámicas cotidianas de vida de
muchos de muchos de nosotros dentro de
estas comunidades
cómo resolvemos el problema de las
pandillas cómo enfrentamos el problema
de pandillas obviamente necesitamos que
en algún punto ellos dejen de ser
pandilleros
y una de las y uno de los mitos que
giran alrededor del tema de las
pandillas es que una vez entre la
pandilla no se sale no que la pandilla
es por vías de por vida que es imposible
salirse de las pandillas y esto digo es
un mito porque se refuerza con este otro
mito de que sólo se sale por los hierros
así como por los hierros sin h ya qué me
refiero bueno se salen dicen ellos sólo
se pueden salir a partir o por el
entierro ser que los maten por el
encierro que vayan a la cárcel donde en
realidad no se salen porque refuerzan su
vínculo con las pandillas o el destierro
que es salen del país
y se mueven a otra comunidad donde
puedan escapar de las pandillas la
pregunta es entonces es posible que un
joven
miembro de pandillas se puede salir se
pueda salir y comenzar una nueva vida y
rehabilitarse
la respuesta pese a lo que oímos
usualmente los medios pessoa lo que se
ha estos mitos es sí por supuesto se
pueden salir sin embargo no es fácil eso
no es fácil y para saberlo mejor
hicimos un estudio yo soy parte de un
grupo de investigadores que por muchos
años hemos venido estudiando el tema de
las pandillas mi primer estudio sobre
pandillas en el salvador lo hice en 1996
cuando la mara salvatrucha a las 18 no
eran lo que son ahora y sin embargo año
tras año
muchos de estos estudios sólo confirman
muchas de las cosas que les voy a contar
ahora mismo el estudio de ves que les
voy a hablar ahora se basa en una
encuesta y una serie de entrevistas en
la cual alcanzamos a casi 1.200
pandilleros y us pandilleros en el país
la mayoría de ellos
ser excluidos en cárceles del país en
centros de detención juvenil y en
programas de rehabilitación que trabajan
y muchas veces esté bajo el agua y lo
digo así porque ellos no quieren generar
mucha atención pero hay programas que
trabajan por rehabilitar a muchos de
estos jóvenes y la validez de estos
estudios viene de la cantidad de jóvenes
con las que hablamos para poder hacer
este estudio sólo les cuento por ejemplo
si ustedes revisan mucha de la
literatura en criminología decir los
estudios que se hacen en eeuu sobre el
tema de pandillas la mayoría de sus
estudios se basan en encuestas son
entrevistas que no alcanzan más de 300 o
400 personas por en el salvador en uno
de los países más peligrosos del mundo
hicimos entrevistamos a 1200 jóvenes
pandilleros y en este momento en este
momento en que les hablo mi equipo está
entrevistando alrededor de mil
pandilleros en honduras y el próximo mes
lo vamos a hacer en guatemala como parte
y esfuerzo mucho más amplio de entender
el fenómeno en la región
es uno de los pocos estudios en realidad
que ha logrado que ha logrado esto de
manera breve a quienes entrevistamos
bueno entrevistamos a muchachos que van
desde los 13 años y hasta no tan
muchachos que van hasta los 55 años más
o menos pero sin embargo si ustedes como
ustedes pueden ver en el gráfico que se
muestra la mayoría están entre que entre
la mayoría gente que entrevistamos están
entre los 15 y los 25 años que
constituye el core el el centro o el
grupo mayor de actividad de los
pandilleros la mayoría de ellos son
hombres claramente los pandilleros
básicas las pandillas están dominadas
por hombres 90 por ciento los que
entrevistamos eran hombres pero había un
grupo importante de mujeres el 10 por
ciento cuya pertenencia usualmente está
vinculada a las relaciones sentimentales
con
con un líder o con un miembro activo de
la pandilla entrevistamos a las
pandillas más grandes al miembro de las
pandillas más grandes por supuesto la ms
que es la más grande aquí en el salvador
en honduras la más grande es la 18 que
sigue que sigue actuando como una sola
como una sola pandilla pero en el sabor
también entrevistamos a 18
revolucionarios y 18 serenos que son que
son las pandillas en las que se ha
dividido la 18 hay otras pequeñas
pandillas de las cuales no se ve mucho
pero que también están presentes en
algunos centros de detención que es el
mensaje importante que sale un poco del
estudio y esto está resumido en algo que
nos dijo uno de los pandilleros que
entrevistamos por más de dos horas y nos
dijo textualmente nos dijo esto la vida
en la pandilla es miserable eso
usualmente no lo oyen públicamente de
los pandilleros pero éste nos lo dijo
así la vida en la pandilla es miserable
uno pasa hambre llora solo no puede
salirse de la pandilla uno sabe que
donde quiera que vaya a uno lo van a
matar y a uno lo persiguen las
autoridades solo por ser parte de la
pandilla este es una declaración de
angustia
y ansiedad y de desesperanza de alguien
que esté en la pandilla este tenía 21
años cuando lo entrevistamos y que
muestra un punto de inflexión a la cual
llegan muchos de estos jóvenes a qué me
refiero con esto
es que cuando ustedes hablan con ellos
la mayor parte de ellos tienen
intenciones de salirse de la pandilla
ellos de ellos te dicen les dicen si yo
pudiera yo me salgo de la pandilla si yo
pudiera me salgo de la pandilla pero
esto usualmente nos lo dicen es
usualmente nos lo dicen aquellos que
tienen mayor edad por qué porque como
vamos les voy a mostrar en un momentito
la mayor parte de jóvenes que están en
la pandilla se meten a la pandilla
cuando tienen entre 11 y 15 años y en
ese momento ellos quieren tener un grupo
de vínculo un grupo de referencia
quieren ser alguien como todos nosotros
queríamos ser alguien y muchas veces lo
único que encuentran como grupo de
referencia es la pandilla son estos que
están ahí y no estos que están ahí en el
barrio que es lo único que ven como su
futuro y entonces quieren ser parte de y
ellos están muy emocionados durante
mucho tiempo durante algún tiempo
mientras son parte de la pandilla
mientras tienen 12 13 14 15 años
pero cuando llegan a los 18 años cuando
llegan los 18 años empiezan a ver
esto no es yo pensé que iba a estar
muerto a esta edad ahora tengo que
planear un futuro tengo que tener una
vida especialmente cuando llega a los 21
años y dice todas estas cosas que hice
es una locura no sabía lo que me estaba
metiendo pero muchas veces cuando llegan
los 21 años a los 18 20 21 22 23 años ya
es muy tarde para muchos porque han
hecho cosas terribles han hecho mal han
cometido cualquier cantidad de delitos
y delitos terribles y sin embargo
piensan como como me salgo de aquí
usualmente es hay cuatro factores que te
ayudan un poco a estas condiciones para
salirse en primer lugar es el tema de la
edad fíjense este gráfico muestra que
tanta importancia le dan los jóvenes a
la pandilla en función de la edad y si
se dan cuenta antes de los 15 años
la pandilla es es todo o casi todo y eso
es todo porque tienen 13 entre 13 y 15
años pero a medida que crecen en la
medida que maduran emocionalmente se dan
cuenta que la pandilla no era lo que
ellos pensaban que era porque han
madurado porque están madurando el
problema es que ya han cometido muchas
cosas han cometido crímenes terribles y
el problema que lo vamos a ver es que
muchas veces no tienen no saben qué
hacer el segundo factor es tener un
trabajo informal es tener una
oportunidad de trabajar en algo eso les
ayuda a poder poder querer salir de las
pandillas
en tercer lugar el ser encarcelado ya
viejo muchas veces se piensa bueno para
resolver esto las pandillas tan pronto
éste se meten o tan pronto empieza a
hacer cosas mientras están chiquitos hay
que meterlos a la cárcel bueno en la
cárcel lo que hacen es reforzar sus
habilidades como pandilleros si los
meten a la cárcel te pequeño bueno lo
van a meter lo van a tener en la cárcel
pero eso no lo va a hacer salirse de la
pandilla en cambio si los meten a la
cárcel viejo eso les cambia la
perspectiva porque de esto ya
probablemente no voy a salir y
finalmente es uno de los factores mucho
más importantes en esta experiencia
religiosa
el vínculo a una iglesia se vuelve
fundamental para que muchos de ellos
decidan salirse de la pandilla y como
ustedes pueden ver ahí cuando les
preguntamos cuáles son las opciones para
salirse de la pandilla la más de la
mitad nos dijo vincularse a una iglesia
otros nos dijeron miren no es que no se
puede salir otros dijeron hay que hablar
con él con el líder o hay que hacer esto
pero la iglesia el vincularse a una
iglesia se mantiene como un
los métodos más efectivos y eso está
reforzado por otros
por otros resultados como pueden ver
ellos piensan que las organizaciones
adecuadas para salirse de las pandillas
es vincularse a una iglesia sin embargo
ellos enfrentan obstáculos
y como he dicho antes ellos han hecho
cosas terribles no estamos hablando de
angelito después de todo han hecho cosas
terribles pero cuando deciden muchos de
ellos salir deciden salirse en realidad
quieren poner todo de sí para poder
construir una nueva vida los obstáculos
sin embargo que enfrentan es la
presencia de la pandilla a final de
cuentas la pandilla sigue ahí no es la
pandilla no se va para ningún lado y
ellos tampoco se pueden ir para ningún
lado y por lo tanto deben enfrentar a la
pandilla que sigue ahí la falta de
oportunidad de trabajo
quizá es crucial porque muchos de ellos
empezaron a meter se metieron a la
pandilla cuando apenas si tenían 12 13
años y nunca aprendieron a hacer nada
más que tirar de un gatillo o amenazar
cierto la falta de habilidades laborales
la amenaza constante de la violencia se
han hecho han cometido crímenes
terribles y por lo tanto siempre hay
gente que se recuerda de eso y que trata
de tomar venganza y la discriminación
social
después de todo muchos de ellos se
tatúan y eso hace muchas veces imposible
salirse de la pandilla sin embargo en la
mayor parte de los casos la experiencia
religiosa juega un papel muy importante
porque porque la iglesia o cualquier
iglesia y especialmente muchas veces las
evangélicas crea una especie de burbuja
que le permite al joven crear nuevas
vínculos y reconstructores les ofrece en
algunos casos oportunidades de trabajo y
sobre todo les ofrece oportunidades de
educación
y eso les ayuda mucho a dejar la vida
anterior sin embargo hay hay modelos
también que no solo son religiosos sino
que son modelos empresariales como el de
él y kolitscher outfitters que es una
máquina que está en camino a santa anna
y que tiene un programa aunque aceptan a
ex pandilleros y que les dan estos
espacios de protección y de y de respeto
una de las cosas que aprendimos con
estos estudios es que obviamente hay que
invertir mucho para que los jóvenes se
salgan de las pandillas pero es posible
y es posible contando con el apoyo no
sólo de los empresarios de la sociedad
sino que también de nosotros mismos
obviamente no todos se van a salir y no
todos tienen intenciones transparentes
de salirse pero aquellos que sí las
tienen tienen que ameritan una
oportunidad yo me quedo con esto y yo
les agradezco mucho su atención
[Aplausos]